I did an episode of insanely chill with
lewig MH and uh you know when someone's
coming on the podcast you do the classic
15 minutes of watching their stuff
before they get on the show right right
and uh and so one of the videos I
watched of his was called The billybilly
Challenge okay he's a streamer I guess
Billy Billy or something like that yeah
he started this trend where it's a
challenge where you go to 10 fast food
places m in like 5 hours and you order
it's a drive-through you have to go to a
drive-thru you have four people with you
or three you're supposed to do it in
teams of four so it's three people with
you yeah so you go to 10 drive-throughs
you order what the person in front of
you ordered and then you have to eat it
all oh so everyone gets together we get
in the car we start driving and I'm like
okay we're right by in andout so let's
go let's go there first it's 11:00 a.m.
it's kind of the perfect time because
the line's probably not going to be too
long y it's probably just going to be
like solo people just getting an early
lunch or something right we pull up
behind two
people a car with two people so we're
like that's not that bad we you know
four of us or five of us yeah can't be
that bad and we pull up to the window
we're like can we get what the person in
front of us just got and the guy's like
okay so you want three double doubles
three animal style fries and a die Coke
and a
shake and we were like oh [__] that's
what we started on we started with that
eat that takes like 20 25 minutes then
we go to who did the shake I think Sam
did most of it or Marcus maybe Marcus
did most of
it it's a heavy thing to start with ice
is tough it's tough but Devon was like
no it's a good bass layer cuz it's basic
you know and then anything you have
that's like acidic you know it kind of
adds a nice little foundation for it so
then we go to Starbucks there's a rule
that you can only do one drink place so
we pull to Starbucks it's a single guy
in front of us we get a black coffee no
milk no sugar beautiful no iced black
coffee pretty much the most ideal thing
you can get in a challenge like that
right so we all shared it took like 5
Seconds to drink this thing this is how
Co started by the
way so then we went to
McDonald's we went to
KFC that's a rule you have to go to a
KFC this gluttony man this is crazy we
went
to
uh oh [__] what else did we go to
between there then I think we went to
ry's Donuts huge mistake
dude come on huge mistake so up until
that point we got lucky we were always
behind I don't know what it was like the
hurricane it was the day that the
hurricane was happening so the rain was
super crazy so I think people were by
the way we just did this mid
hurricane we're like hydroplaning like
everyone related to you until that
moment why what do you mean that's just
a wild thing to do like yo Let's do
let's do like a drive-thru mukbang video
like during a
hurricane it'll be the rain was supposed
to be not that crazy you know but it was
it wasn't that crazy we never felt
unsafe until like the way back home
that's you all have that food in your
stomach [__] cuz I was falling asleep at
the steering wheel so we got pretty
lucky like we were only getting single
items cuz there was a lot of like single
riders that just like popped out for
lunch real fast and so it was like
McDonald's we got a quarter pound or a
cheese just one beautiful beautiful
order KFC we got [__] chicken littles
kind of gross okay not a big fan of
those okay and then and then we go to
ry's Donuts we're like this would be
great right halfway we'll get a little
dessert and then we'll have dinner we
had lunch dessert now we'll have dinner
after that it's like this is a Sunday
right it's like families going there and
getting dozens of
donuts we get stuck with luckily it was
half a
dozen but they were like massive massive
donuts and one of them was this
horrendous apple
fritter that was dense this thing was 14
PBS by
itself you felt that when the box came
into your hand I was like thank
you drops on the
lap we struggled dude I had to get out
and puke like just Auto puke like I can
do in the garbage and there's like
families like looking at me just want to
remind everyone that yeah yeah I I don't
pull trigger though I don't have to put
my fingers in my throat I can just puke
I could do it right now just sitting
here prove yeah please no I've seen him
do it so many times no dude don't do it
I hate when you do this [__] oh it's so
F if you want to see me do it you got to
watch my video yeah this is this is Cody
coming out of a restaurant
ready I do not feel good that I don't
know that's kind of weird hold
on that's actually that's a perfect
impression and then everyone's like CU I
I only have to all I have to do
is lean forward a little bit and then I
can I don't have to go like this I don't
have to do I don't do that [__] I go I
mean I could do it right here just on my
shirt don't over please don't and then
here's the most disgusting part he goes
over here and he just
goes he's wiping his lips and you're
like what and you're like I just threw
up real
[Laughter]
quick I just Foo up real quick
I f up I just FW up yeah all right so
you I can't believe we're I'm admitting
this in front of Ariana too it's kind of
embarrassing
anyway so I threw up these Ry Donuts too
there was three glaze those were the
good ones yeah and there was a maple one
with like an inch worth of icing on it
and then this apple fritter dude took us
like an hour to get through these things
yeah finally get get through them we go
to Del
[Laughter]
Taco no that [__] actually kind of ruled
Del Taco we Delo we get in line behind a
big boy oh sh big old truck and a big
boy right and so we're like damn what's
he what's he going to order yeah and we
pulled to the window it was a c style
burrito and Fries but he um what's the
word they use for like super sizing it
mhm it's like it's like mucho yeah
whatever something like that yeah
something Spanish but it's a funny it's
like a funny way of saying it basically
he's like um and so it was a fat C
burrito with tons of fries smash that
the worst one by far was Burger King by
far yeah that place is trash and I'm
sure that hurt Marcus cuz that boy loves
the be no but after that he was like no
this play like the mem's over this place
[__] sucks yeah
it really does like I'm floored by how
bad quality it is everything sucks what
would you get like we got stuck with
like a double double whopper or no
what's what's the one from Burger King
Whopper that McDonald it's a Whopper
it's a Whopper yeah it was like a triple
whopper or some [__] like that so it was
a lot of meat yeah but the Patty was
just cardboard yeah was insane yeah and
then Deon ended up blending it up cuz we
had a blender and trying to drink
it
yeah dude he blended it up with fruit
punch cuz that's the drink we got
oh so we spent another 30 minutes
vomiting in yeah in the rain yeah the
last place we go was [__] elpo Loco
we got stuck with like a tostada salad
it's like just a normal salad with like
beans and rice but it's in one of the
tostada bowls yeah and it just was like
wet yeah [__] was just dripping wet for
some reason why yeah it was just wet I
made a face very moist cuz I was
thinking you got stuck with a full
chicken from Bo yeah just a could you
like the equivalent to rotisserie
chicken that would oh my God man I can't
just get so you'll take the full chicken
with no
sauce yeah I guess I
will
y just Yum Chicken no sauce just white
as [__] eating it off the [__]
bones is throwing up allowed because I
feel like it's broken nope you got to
let that [__] soak
whoops